in this video we're going to get
introduced to the Pythagorean theorem
Pythagorean Pythagorean theorem which is
fun on its own but you'll see as you
learn more and more mathematics it's one
of those cornerstone theorems of of
really all of math it's useful in
geometry it's kind of the backbone of
trigonometry you're also going to use it
to calculate distances between points so
it's a good thing to to really make sure
we know well so let's let them enough
talk on my and let me tell you what the
Pythagorean theorem is so if we have a
triangle and the triangle has to be a
right triangle so it has to be a right
triangle which means that one of the
three angles in the triangle have to be
90 degrees and you specify that it's 90
degrees by drawing that little box right
there so that right there is let me do
this in a different color
that right there is a 90 degree 90
degree angle or we could call it a right
a right angle and a triangle that has a
right angle and it is called a right
triangle so this is called a right right
triangle now with the Pythagorean
theorem if we know two sides of a right
triangle we can always figure out the
third side and before I show you how to
do that let me give you one more piece
of terminology the longest side of a
pythagorean of a right triangle is the
side opposite the 90 degree angle or
opposite the right angle so in this case
it is this side right here this is the
longest side and the way to tell figure
out where that right triangle is and you
kind of it opens into that longest side
that longest side is called the
hypotenuse hypotenuse and it's good to
know because we'll keep referring to it
and I just just so we always are good at
identifying the hypotenuse let me draw a
couple of more right triangles
so let's say I have a triangle that
looks like that a triangle that looks
let me draw it a little bit nicer so
let's say I have a triangle that looks
like that and I were to tell you that
this angle right here is 90 degrees in
this situation this is the hypotenuse
because it is opposite it is opposite
the 90 degree angle it is the longest
side let me do one more just so that
we're good at recognizing the hypotenuse
so let's say that that is my triangle
and this is the 90 degree angle right
there and I think you know how to do
this already you go right what it opens
into that is the hypotenuse that is the
longest side the longest side so that is
the hypotenuse so once you have
identified the hypotenuse so let's say
that that has length C and now we're
going to learn what the Pythagorean
theorem tells us so let's say that C is
equal to the length of the hypotenuse so
let's call this C that side is C let's
call this side right over here let's
call this side right over here a and
let's call this side over here B so the
Pythagorean theorem tells us that a
squared so one of the shorter sides the
length of one of the shorter sides
squared plus the length of the other
shorter side squared is going to be
equal to the length of the hypotenuse
squared now let's do that with an actual
problem and you'll see that it's
actually not so bad so let's say that I
have a triangle that looks like this let
me draw it let's say that this is my
triangle looks something like this and
let's say that they tell us that this is
the right angle that this length right
here let me do this in different colors
this length right here is 3 and that
this length right here is 4 and they
want us to figure out they want us to
figure out that length right there now
the first thing you want to do before
you even apply the Pythagorean theorem
is to make sure you have your hypotenuse
straight you make sure you know what
you're solving for and in this
circumstance we're solving for the
height
and we know that because this side over
here it is the side opposite opposite
the right angle if we look at the
Pythagorean theorem this is C this is
the longest side so now we're ready to
apply we're ready to apply the
Pythagorean theorem it tells us that
four squared one of the shorter sides
plus three squared plus three squared
the square of another of the shorter
sides is going to be equal to this
longer side squared the hypotenuse
squared is going to be equal to C
squared and then you just solve for C so
4 squared is the same thing as 4 times 4
that is 16 and 3 squared is the same
thing as 3 times 3 so that is 9 and that
is going to be equal to is equal to C
squared now what is 16 plus 9 it's 25 so
25 is equal to C squared and we could
take the positive square root of both
sides see I guess just look at it
mathematically could be negative 5 as
well but we're dealing with distances so
we only care about the positive roots so
you take the principal root of both
sides and you get 5 is equal to C or the
length of the longest side is equal to
is equal to 5 now you could use the
Pythagorean theorem if we give you two
of the sides to figure out the third
side no matter what the third side is so
let's do another one right over here
let's say let's say that our triangle
looks like let's say our triangle looks
something like let's say our triangle
looks like this and that is our right
angle let's say that this side over here
has length 12 and let's say that this
side over here has length 6 and we want
to figure out we want to figure out this
length right over there now like I said
the first thing you want to do is
identify the hypotenuse and that's going
to be the side opposite the right angle
we have the right angle here you go
opposite the right angle the longest
side the hypotenuse
is right there so if we think about the
if we think about the Pythagorean
theorem that a squared plus B squared is
equal to C squared 12 you could view as
C this is the hypotenuse the hypotenuse
the C squared is the hypotenuse squared
so you could say 12 is equal to C and
then we could set these sides it doesn't
matter whether you call one of them a or
one of them B so let's just call this
side right here let's say a is equal to
6 and then we say B this colored B is
equal to question mark and now we can
apply the Pythagorean theorem a squared
which is 6 squared 6 squared plus the
unknown B squared plus B squared is
equal to the hypotenuse squared is equal
to C squared is equal to 12 squared and
now we can solve for B and notice the
difference here now we're not solving
for the hypotenuse we're solving for one
of the shorter sides in the last example
we solved for the hypotenuse we solved
for C so that's why it's always
important to recognize that the a
squared plus B squared plus C squared C
is the length of the hypotenuse let's
just solve for B here so we get 6
squared is 36 plus b squared plus b
squared is equal to 12 squared that's 12
times 12 is 144 now we can subtract 36
from both sides of this equation
subtract 36 those cancel out on the left
hand side we're left with just a b
squared is equal to now 144 minus 36 is
what that is 144 minus 30 is 114 and
then you might subtract 6 it's 108 so
this is going to be 108 so that's what B
squared is and now we want to take the
principal root or the positive root of
both sides and you get B is equal to the
square root the principal root of 108
now let's see if we can simplify this a
little bit the square root of 108
what we could do is we could take the
prime factorization of 108 and see how
we can simplify this radical so 108 is
the same thing as let's see it's the
same thing as 2 times 54 which is the
same thing as 2 times 27 which is the
same thing as 3 times 9 so we have the
square root square root of 108 is the
same thing as the square root of 2 times
2 times actually I'm not done 9 can be
factorized into 3 times 3 so it's 2
times 2 times 3 times 3 times 3 and so
we have a couple of perfect squares in
here let me rewrite it a little bit
neater and this is all an exercise in
simplifying radicals that you will bump
into a lot while doing the Pythagorean
theorem so it doesn't hurt to do it
right here so this is the same thing as
so this is the same thing as the square
root of 2 times 2 times 3 times 3 times
the square root of that last 3 right
over there and this is the same thing
and you know you would you wouldn't have
to do all of this in your head well all
of this on paper you could do it in your
head what is this 2 times 2 is 4 4 times
9 this is 36 this is the square root of
36 times the square root of 3 the
principal root of 36 is 6 so this
simplifies to 6 square roots of 3 so the
length of B you could write a square
root of 108 or you could say it's equal
to 6 times the square root of 3 this is
12 this is 6 and the square root of 3
well this is going to be a 1 point
something something so it's going to be
a little bit larger than 6